join the jaegers tonight we are
canceling the apocalypse but really just
postponing it a little bit because we
have a signal via another probably
another apocalypse city fire a bigger a
pirate or later this is just the preview
pocket
what is happening reject Nations it's
Greg alpha hey and it's John Humphrey
over here Comic Con is upon us
people Pacific Rim uprising the sequel
that is not from Guillermo del Toro it's
here right Steven F tonight director of
many episodes of TV is directing the
producers and Dara one of the directors
from that episode of daredevil II I I'm
excited for this I am pins in it very
curious young mega ya Moses
what is a gator
the jaegers the pinnacle of human
invention claim amongst just came we did
not wait for Heroes to fall from the sky
and save us we saved ourselves
innovation is ours to the pound
wonder bigger accused kinds of thousands
called as a mountain with a beating
heart diseases right become the most
turmeric version where I joined a llegar
cool hell yeah that's pretty sweet I
like that that like commercial motif
yeah a viral video type of comic-con
trailer you would totally get perfectly
sci-fi a perfectly slightly unsettling
almost yeah way that robot auto-tuned
voice sounds I think this is a great way
to to rebuild you back up for Pacific
Rim because in the day and age that
we're in when Pacific Rim has been a
while considering that movies are what
sequels nowadays it's been a while
there's a lot of Pacific Rim and it's a
great way to tease it and if the movies
anything like how this little viral
video is doing it I'd imagine that the
movie is going to have more fun with
what it is because I was something that
the first Pacific Rim was kind of like I
felt like you could have had a little
bit more fun with its tone and the
characters here with just that kind of
clip even though it's probably a clip
that's not from the actual film it does
have this sense of fun and excitement
yeah yeah or sliding monsters kind you
you know I hope in the movie has a tone
and style of what this teaser trailer
was conveying well yeah it is sort of a
future Society and at least when I see
ads like this you know I know alien and
Prometheus do them a lot I always got to
think like these are kind of the world
the extra world building stuff so I'm
interested to see what the society in
this new Pacific Rim movie is like you
know totally because the world came
together the first one to fight the kind
you because I've learnt a much bigger
recruiting process at the Doudna video
called joined oh yeah you're here now
yet when you're operating yeah yeah that
makes me just wonder all the more about
what the actual plot can it be you know
an all-star because the story is going
to be and you know John boyega
it was actual voices time yeah yeah yeah
I've been found I did to detect the
block so I'm just excited you know that
he's in this yet he's becoming like our
sci-fi star
yeah yeah dude awesome ladies like the
black Chris Pratt or the or the new Will
Smith he's a sci-fi action star now with
attack the block Star Wars an a Pacific
or anything yeah I'll take it all today
John Barry was awesome man he's awesome
yeah alright guys you excited for
Pacific Rim uprising you started from
Morgan released from comic-con it really
it's a full trailer doubt it but who
knows alright well you can subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
bell - on Humphrey on Twitter and
Instagram and go check out our patreon
for its exclusive percent rewards
everything goes to helping keep this
channel alive and we'll of just have you
part of the community of throwing over
there it's very interactive to notice we
are canceling the apocalypse
Lord and a child will help with
consoling the enemy yep okay this will
still be around the picture will help
you survive indeed and a commercial for
Yeager's and canceled the apocalypse
every video I think ur had on it from
now